six one seven eight three zero 4750 is
the number let's go to our caller from
972 who's been holding on for a while
who's there at nine seven two hello this
is Tanner in Dallas and I was wondering
if there could be any evidence in the
Trump Russia investigation that could be
so damning and so overwhelming that not
only it could force a impeachment but
maybe even an early presidential
election uh a presidential election I
think the answer is no but let's talk
about the first one which is could what
what evidence if it came out would force
an impeach so Tanner let me ask you this
do you mean something that's so bad that
even a Republican House and Senate moves
to impeach and then convict Trump or do
you mean not necessarily a Republican
house in the Senate I think it would be
I think both parties would what could be
so bad that no one in the House and
Senate can say this guy needs to stay I
think no I mean I can in that everything
I have it would have to be so bad as to
be cartoonish where I'm almost like
embarrassed to say how bad it would be
yeah I also think that if there had some
kind of direct connection maybe money
connection that pump that Putin paid
Trump directly or maybe personal cash
like Newton gave money yeah Trump like a
cycle of a bull years old or something
like that you know even that I feel like
they'd figure out a way to say this is
totally totally legal this is there's
nothing wrong with us whatsoever we're
making deals if there were tapes there
would be doctored case I also wanted to
break up the early presidential election
idea because I got a thinkin yeah I
don't think so that you don't think so
well like I just don't think it would
just be pens takes over and he and he
wants and he thinks that there could be
a possibility for that so sorry I think
for a fact from him yet but I think it
would be really interesting to see
that's really unprecedented
yeah all right well we'll keep an eye on
that I think we're having a very unusual
action issue but I do appreciate the
call and we will investigate any and all
of these questions if you're holding on
please don't hang up we will take more
calls after a quick break don't hang up
if you're holding on we are taking more
calls